top
uh we tried to wait until after the um
background or on the india bylat as well
so hopefully you were able to listen in
on that
today as part of the fight to help
americans deal with high costs the vice
president is announcing new actions to
protect consumers and lessen the burden
of medical debt on american families
she'll be joined by administration
leaders including hhs secretary basara
cfpb director chopra and omb director
young medical debt is now the largest
source of debt in collections more than
credit cards utilities and auto loans
combined but it is not just a financial
issue it can have negative health
effects too studies have found that
americans with medical debt are more
likely to avoid seeking additional
medical care than those without debt
getting sick or taking care of loved
ones should not mean financial hardship
for american families that is why the
administration is going to hold medical
providers and debt collectors
accountable for harmful practices reduce
the role that medical debt plays in
determining whether americans can access
credit help over half a million of
low-income american veterans get their
medical debt forgiven and inform
consumers of their rights these actions
come on the heels of the president's
april 5th executive order on access to
affordable quality health care coverage
also wanted to note that today our
administration launched a rural
infrastructure tour to double down on
the president's unwavering commitment to
building a better america where rural
communities thrive the white house
released a rural playbook to help state
local tribal and territorial governments
in rural areas unlock the historic
investments from the president's
bipartisan infrastructure law this
playbook offers a what when where and
how to apply for funding under the law
making it easier for rural communities
to plan and compete for federal
resources that create good-paying jobs
and generate economic opportunities
secretary holland is kicking off the
tour in boulder county colorado today
and during the month of april cabinet
members and biden administration
officials will travel to dozens of rural
communities to talk about how we are
unlocking bipartisan infrastructure law
investments and federal resources to
make sure they reach rural areas across
america this tour includes the
president's trip tomorrow to menlo iowa
outside of des moines to discuss our
the administration's actions to lower
costs for working families there
president biden will make an
announcement on actions to reduce the
impact of putin's price hike and build
america a better america with
investments in rural communities from
the bipartisan infrastructure law and
welcome back karine her first day back
we're very thrilled to have her back
here with us in the briefing room okay
with that
i've got three things i'll show you
pretty quickly um
as you just mentioned the president's
going to iowa's part of the world
playbook launch um he's visiting a state
that he he lost during the 2020 campaign
and he's going through county that was
even more a voting republican last time
i'm wondering if that will make it
harder to
for that area to receive his message
politically
well i think the president is not making
this trip through a political prison
he's making this trip because iowa is a
rural state in the country that would
benefit greatly from the president's
policies including the uh policies that
he'll be talking about uh tomorrow on
his trip uh when he was running i think
many of you heard him say and convey he
wanted to be the president for all
people whether you voted for him or not
and this is certainly an example of this
effort to do exactly that
um on another topic uh look at the
bilateral um how much did the president
push uh the prime minister to limit
russian energy imports and arms and what
was the response well uh we'll let the
indian government
project their response or not their
response but their readout of the call i
would say that
energy
imports are not banned they don't
violate our sanctions we certainly
recognize every country is going to uh
take uh steps that are in their interest
at the same time on this call what the
president did is is consistent with what
uh our deputy national security adviser
of course did uh during his visit just a
few weeks ago was to make clear what the
impact of course of our sanctions would
be we expect everybody to abide by those
and well uh india is uh only imports
about one to two percent of its energy
uh from russia we also made clear and
the president made clear that we would
be happy to help them in diversifying uh
this as well um in terms of um
[Music]
and also made clear i should say uh that
the president also made clear that he
does not believe it's in india's
interest to accelerate or increase
imports of russian energy and other
commodities uh as well um and uh which
is something we certainly convey to
other countries uh in terms of um
military um
uh military actions uh so uh that we
have not made a decision about the
waiver under kata um in terms of how
much it was discussed during the call
i'd have to get uh more details from our
national security team on that
specifically go ahead on the new rule uh
today this is already facing the threat
of legal challenges challenges from some
uh
gun groups given those threats are you
bracing for legal challenges when you
realistically expect to see this view
will take effect given those challenges
well let me first say that um this rule
uh or the intention to put this rule
forward was announced as you know some
time ago and there was a lot of response
to it 250 000 comments which is of
course a lot to go through what this is
a reflection of and why the president is
of course confident are hopeful about
our ability to ensure we can continue to
implement it is the fact that ghost guns
uh kill people too uh ghost guns uh can
be purchased online people put together
these kits uh they're not background
checks that are required they're not
under the same uh they're not uh also um
uh required to um
to have serial numbers uh which makes it
more difficult for law enforcement to
track when these have an impact um in uh
in crimes so of course the president is
confident in any executive order in the
legal authority that he puts forward but
what's important to note about the
announcement he is making today is that
this is
this is a rule that is supported by law
enforcement it is a rule that will help
address what we know is a rising
component of gun uh crimes across the
country which is the use of ghost guns
and to the president was important to
take a step to address that
going on what you just said police tell
us that these guns are as simple as
clicking on the internet and snapping
parts together will there be can you say
this administration say there will be
fewer shootings as a result of what the
president is doing today well that's
always our hope and our objective right
is to reduce the impact of gun violence
as we've seen violence go up
we have seen a huge vast majority of
that nearly three-quarters as a result
of guns and ghost guns as you said
cecilia are used by simply clicking and
ordering online ordering a kit that
people can make in their homes and that
is one of the reasons why this
this action or efforts to take uh more
steps has been supported by a range of
law enforcement officials from
the international association of chiefs
of police said that ghost guns are quote
increasingly used by criminals and
terrorists we saw governor larry hogan
of course a republican as you know call
maryland's ban
bill bannon ghost guns a positive step
as we seek to stem the tide of violent
crime uh brown county wisconsin
lieutenant uh matt rank matt ronk said
ghost guns are quote a new threat and
there are a range of police leaders and
officials across the country who have
conveyed uh how important both these
these components that the president is
announcing today are to uh to addressing
uh the threat of ghost guns
just to follow up did the president get
a commitment from prime minister modi
not to accelerate or increase imports of
russian energy
i'll let uh prime minister modi and the
indians speak to that again it's one to
two percent at this point in time it is
not they they import ten percent from
the united states uh it is not a
violation of any sanctions or anything
along those lines it was a constructive
uh direct conversation
but i will let them speak for themselves
secondly the president said he wanted to
meet prime minister modi in tokyo honor
about may 24th what else can you tell us
about this trip
the president is looking forward to
going to asia at some point but i don't
have any more details at this point in
time clearly he's excited since he
talked about it today and lastly any
details about this announcement tomorrow
in iowa is it related to ethanol i don't
have any more details at this point in
time as you all know we are taking a
range of steps to um to reduce uh the
price of gas uh to move us toward a
long-term more clean energy economy but
i expect we'll have more of a preview
for you later today go ahead thanks jen
um back to the conversation with modi
did the president urge modi to speak out
more forcefully against the russian
invasion well we have seen
the indians do exactly that more
recently as they did as it relates to
the
horrific photos that we saw around busha
we've seen them take steps to provide
humanitarian assistance and a range of
assistance but it is something we always
encourage leaders to do uh to speak out
to be vocal uh to ensure they on the
right side of history but this was a
constructive call it was a productive
call um it was it's a relationship that
is vitally important to the united
states and to the president i would not
see it as an adversarial call and then i
understand you want to let the indians
speak for themselves but
was the president seeking a promise from
modi that he wouldn't
look to increase
oil purchases from russia well we are uh
the president both conveyed that we are
here to help them diversify uh their
means of uh importing oil again our the
imports from the united states are
already significant uh or much bigger
than the imports that they get from
russia
and we of course the president conveyed
very clearly that it is not in their
interest to increase that but beyond
that i would let the indian leaders
speak for themselves
i'm wondering if you know last night
ukrainian president vladimir's elizabeth
told 60 minutes that the ukrainian
military has
recordings of conversations between
russian troops talking about committing
atrocities that would qualify as war
crimes wondering if anyone in the u.s
government has been able to listen to
these intercepts or whether the us
government has similar intercepts well i
don't have anything to confirm on that
front from here but what i would
reiterate is something jake sullivan
said last week which is that as we're
looking to provide data and information
to war crimes investigations of which
there are a range of options currently
underway the osce obviously the icc the
ukrainian special prosecutor is
also gathering information we're going
to provide any data and information we
can and we're going to encourage other
countries to do exactly that we've
already called a range of these actions
we've seen war crimes that is
important but there's also going to be
an investigative step where all of this
will be uh will be fed into that can
also take some time
is that something that the white house
we're not going to prejudge which format
or forum that it can take there are a
range of different options that history
has utilized whether it's the icc or
the oste and basically an international
fora is probably the appropriate form
but we're not going to predetermine what
that looks like go ahead thank you jen
does the us intend to return its
diplomatic presence to keith that is of
course our objective over the course of
time but we're going to have to assess
when it's the right time to do exactly
that is it considering moving back into
ukraine
potentially to lev sooner rather than
later i don't have a prediction of that
at this point obviously we it's in our
interest to have a diplomatic presence
on the ground but that is an assessment
made by the state department uh made
through the prism of security
considerations and sometimes it's a
smaller presence that gets larger but
they are really the appropriate entity
to speak to that is there any concern
that if the us does not get his
diplomatic presence back
sooner that it'll appear that we're
leading from behind as you've got the
european union i believe the czech
republic italy
a lot of countries are coming forward
and saying that they're going back to
ukraine and the u.s hasn't done it i
would say that uh the most important
thing the united states has done and
continues to do is lead the entire
global coalition and standing up against
russia and ensuring we are providing
military security assistance expediting
that tapping into not only our own
resources but the resources of countries
around the world and leading the world
in a package of economic sanctions that
has had a crippling impact on the
russian economy those are the most
important factors
to go to ukraine
i'm not going to get into private
conversations uh what i will is we're
not currently playing a trip
by the president of the united states to
ukraine what is most important to the
ukrainian leadership is that we are
expediting weapons and getting them the
assistance and security systems they
need and that is what our focus is on
who decides if the president goes to
ukraine or not
in what way he had said when he was in
poland that he expressed interest in
going to ukraine but they wouldn't let
me so i'm wondering who i'm not going to
get into private considerations
internally on that front
title 42 um you said over the weekend
that um the administration agrees more
needs to be done the immigration system
is broken this was in response to a
question about democrats who don't want
to lift it right now
he invited republicans to work with the
white house to get something done on
immigration but has the white house
actually reached out to any republicans
to try to move this forward recently it
has been a long-standing open invitation
uh any republican who wants to work with
us on immigration reform you're invited
let's have a conversation we've not seen
an expression of that interest across
the board
so you're wanting republicans to go to
you the white house is not reaching out
to anyone we have conversations with
democrats and republicans all the time
jackie but i think it's clear what we're
seeing from republicans is an effort to
politicize this and not fix what we all
recognize as an outdated and broken
system one last question you said on
friday that um the vice president was
masked indoors all day
but the white house tweeted a video
showing her standing over the president
without a mask on can you explain what
happened there well i would say that the
vice president and the president and all
of us abide by what the cdc protocols
are it was an emotional day it was a
historic day and there were moments when
she was not wearing a mask inside
including in a photo but she was wearing
at 99.9 percent of the time i would note
the president and the vice president
have both tested negative uh in the last
24 hours and you know we have felt and
made the decision it's important for to
share with all of you um when there are
close contacts that's exactly what we
did why it's of interest to the public i
think is uh and you guys can agree or
disagree with me is because the four
principles the public has a a right to
know and an interest in knowing uh when
the four principals have uh have
exposure or close contact exposure uh to
any individuals who have covered the the
vice president is now post five days
post exposure she tested negative
oh go do it
sorry i'll go to kate and but
go ahead sorry i jumped around i didn't
mean to go ahead speaking of india's
response to russia's invasion
they have abstained from several votes
united nations condemning the invasion
suspending russia from the human rights
council did president biden raise that
during their call today
i don't have any more details beyond
what was raised or briefed out in the
background call obviously the call
concluded we just did a briefing call i
don't have any more details beyond that
you can't say if president biden asked
them to condemn the invasion
they have condemned the recent horrific
atrocities we saw in busha and certainly
as we see more we expect them to do
exactly that as well what does the us
assess this new russian general
overseeing the invasion
meaning for it going forward well i
would say our view is that um even a
changeover in personnel or leadership at
the top is not going to uh to erase the
fact that this is a strategic uh a
failure for russia what we should all be
aware of and we are certainly aware of
is this is a general who uh
was already responsible for overseeing
atrocities in syria uh and that uh we
would we would expect that it would be a
continuation of the type of atrocities
we've already seen take place in ukraine
but again
they have not um it is not gone as
president putin has planned um and we
don't expect a change in personnel would
change that are you concerned it could
get worse
well i think caitlyn separate from any
change of leadership at the top what we
have seen or we expect is as they have
coalesced their uh sort their um their
resources and their uh their um um you
know
all of the resources that they have into
eastern most of them i should say into
eastern ukraine we certainly expect that
they will surround and overwhelm
ukrainian forces in that part of the
country we expect russia will continue
to launch air and missile strikes across
the rest of the country to cause
military and economic damage and we
expect this stage of the conflict could
last a long time and we should have no
illusions that russia is going to adjust
their tactics and make them less brutal
and certainly uh changes in leadership
reflect a continuation of the type of
atrocities we've seen or the type of
approach that we've seen and we've also
predicted from the beginning and just to
follow on jackie's question what is the
threshold for reopening the u.s embassy
in kiev i'd point you to the state
department if they have any more
specifics they want to outline publicly
obviously we want to have a diplomatic
uh really uh presence on the ground
that's always going to be our objective
what oh kelly go ahead go ahead
it's been years since there's been a
confirmed atf director yeah and uh what
do you think will be different now with
this new nomination the president is
putting forward and do you think the
absence of that uh kind of leadership
has had any part in
the increase in gun violence the country
has seen
well i it's hard for it's hard for me to
make a conclusion or us to make a
conclusion on that from here but what i
what we know is that having uh confirmed
leadership uh leading any agency
including one as important as the atf
always is going to make the systems the
processes the ability to get policy
making done
more efficient and effective and there's
no question it's a net positive to have
someone confirmed um to lead uh atf i i
would say that um
you know steve who is our our nominee or
announced a nominee is a
highly qualified candidate with decades
of law enforcement experience including
through partnerships with the atf to
prosecute complex cases and take down
violent criminal gangs he's received
bipartisan support from law enforcement
leaders he was confirmed unanimously
when he was nominated to serve as a
federal prosecutor and our view is that
if republicans are
about getting tough on crime as we are
and keeping our communities safe they
should support a career prosecutor like
steve detelbach who can make atf more
effective in getting guns off our
streets and stopping criminals and it's
in all of our interests to have a
confirmed nominee and we think he is
eminently qualified to do exactly that
and just to follow on the issue of the
vice president and the masking a couple
of times you've cited emotional day
important day important role she was
playing you're not saying that those
things
are reasons to not follow cdc absolutely
not and i appreciate your question on
that what i was conveying is that
you know while she has worn a mask as is
protocol and as is our expectation of
everyone from the vice president the
president all of us on down if you have
a close contact uh that there was a
photo as uh jackie said and there there
are moments when yeah she was human and
uh she didn't have a fat mask on in a
photo um but she has worn the mask and
certainly that is what we want to con
convey to the american people is it
because of the photo because it's an
important day and the photo will live
for decades that
we all understand i mean i'm wearing a
mask today don't always wear a mask yeah
is that the reason i think it was a
decision made in the moment uh but it
doesn't mean that we don't uh all uh try
to be model citizens here and abide by
what the cdc protocols are and
requirements and i conveyed and wanted
to reiterate that she did test negative
in case those of you had not seen that
because she now is at that five-day uh
past the close contact go ahead oh jim
thank you um pakistan's prime minister
imran khan was deposed this weekend
following a no confidence vote in
parliament what is the administration's
reaction to those developments and does
president biden have any plans to speak
with the country's new prime minister
shabbat shari
so
we support the peaceful upholding of
constitutional democratic principles we
don't support one political party over
another and we certainly
support the principles of rule of law
and equal justice under the law we value
our long-standing cooperation with
pakistan have always viewed a prosperous
and democratic pakistan as critical to
you as interests that remains unchanged
regardless of who leadership is in terms
of a future call and have anything to
predict at this point in time obviously
we stay in close touch with them at a
range of levels one more question on the
president's call with prime minister
modi was india's acquisition of the s
400 missile defense system from russia a
topic of discussion and do you have any
updates on whether the u.s would impose
sanctions that would be triggered under
kata or issue a waiver should india go
through with that purchase yeah i i um
i don't have an update as i said kind of
to an earlier question on the katsa
waiver that would be required um i don't
have an update at this point in time i
can see if there's more to report out to
you before the end of the day go ahead
tomorrow's cpi today i was probably
obviously gonna capture at the start of
the war and get pretty significant
spikes in energy can you give us a sense
of what you're expecting and what if any
change this will make for uh what talks
may or may not be going on with the hill
on
what
pieces that may or may not be passed of
a bill that may or may not have a name
sounds very hypothetical and hopeful
okay
um so because of the actions we've taken
to address uh putin the putin price hike
we are in a better place than we were
last month
but we expect march cpa cpi headline
inflation to be extraordinarily elevated
due to putin's price hike and we expect
a large difference between core and
headline inflation reflecting the global
disruptions in energy and food markets
so corn inflation doesn't include energy
and food prices uh headline inflation
does and of course we know that core
inflation you know energy the impact of
energy of course on oil prices gas
prices we expect that to uh continue to
reflect what we've seen uh the increases
be over the course of this invasion and
just as an example since president
putin's military buildup accelerated in
january average gas prices are up more
than 80 cents most of the increase in
occurred in the month of march and at
times gas prices were more than a dollar
above pre-invasion level so that roughly
25 percent increase in gas prices will
drive tomorrow's inflation reading and
certainly it's not a surprise to us but
we certainly think it will be reflected
and in march again to give you a point
of comparison the average cost of a
barrel of oil was around 110 that's
compared to about 75
at the beginning of the year so we
expect this to all be reflected as we
look at the data uh tomorrow uh i will
say that um anytime there are heightened
uh monthly data uh or uh
inflation uh reporting or numbers it is
a reminder to us to uh our our allies on
the hill and hopefully to many of the
american people that we need to do more
to reduce costs for the american people
uh we have of course uh legislation that
could do exactly that cut the cost of
child care of health care of elder care
these all have enormous impact packs on
people's budgets on when they're you
know doing those calculations at their
kitchen table and and certainly this
data will be a reminder of uh the uh the
need to do something and take additional
steps
yes do you have anything to share on
next steps for that
how quickly would tariffs on russian
goods change yeah that's a great
question let me see if i can get you a
more how how quickly would be
implemented you know when they would see
the tariffs as you're asking okay
finally the announcement this afternoon
on gun first backdrop into this is a lot
of cities are seeing significant uh
instances of gun crime or
violent crime more generally i think
there's an update of where the
administration stands on
a push for police reform package to pass
through congress are those talks
ongoing at all
or is the calculus of the sort of
escalation and crime has made it even
more difficult to pass the police reform
package right now
well i i would say first on on gun
violence which we do recognize as an
enormous problem and of course a driver
of what we've seen as the rising uh
rising rates of crime across the country
for some time um you know we are going
to continue to call on congress to do
more uh we're not going to wait uh while
lives are being lost and when more
reforms need to be put in place so i
mean i think there's like kind of two
components here there's obviously police
reform uh there were bipartisan
conversations we sort of paused on our
review of an executive order for that
period of time out of respect for that
process obviously that's not a process
that is rapidly moving forward we're
continuing to
review and have every intention of the
president signing an executive order on
police reform i would note that we have
also taken steps from the department of
justice to ban chokeholds and take other
steps that we have the capacity to do
from the federal government but in order
to
make
reforms
impactful over the long term and more
expansive we need legislation on guns um
you know we have also taken steps out
the president has done more to fight gun
violence and keep our communities safe
than any president in history in his
first year in office this is obviously
an issue that is close to his heart
something he's passionate about and has
been for decades and choking off the
supply of guns being used in crimes
including by cracking down on gun
traffickers and firearms dealers
who are selling guns illegally is one of
the steps we've taken but also we've
taken steps to put more cops on the beat
investing uh improving community-based
programs to make our streets safer doing
all of this to prop up while also
supporting reforms local police make
sure they have the funding they need
while also putting in place in whatever
capacity we have gun reforms measures as
the president is doing today to help
address some of the rising impacts like
ghost guns
right now there's no appetite in
congress to pass that
i don't want to speak for congress and
and so they can speak for that and what
they think the potential is and
obviously we're going to continue to
advocate for that to push for that to
press for that but we're not going to uh
wait to take additional steps that we
have the executive authority to take but
um if i can circle back to the call of
what the president had earlier today
with the prime minister of india um a
senior administration official did brief
us earlier today and said that
we haven't asked india to do anything in
particular this was on energy imports
but then later said we don't think
russia should accelerate imports from
russian oil so can you tell us
did the president explicitly ask not for
an acceleration of question it's more as
it was articulated and i just
articulated i hope maybe not clearly
about conveying that we don't think it's
in their interests to
import more russian oil they're only
importing one to two percent at this
point in time we're here to diversify
and help them diversify as we've done
with other european countries should
they make that choice to do they're not
violating any sanctions by importing oil
it's a decision we made from the united
states but we also recognize different
countries have their own calculations
it was conveying exactly the how i just
described it can actually one other
question on inflation you were referring
just a minute ago to the consequences of
russia's invasion of ukraine and
putin and we've offered the
administration
i just got back actually last week i was
at michigan talking to a lot of voters
who told me that they feel that the
inflation has predated the war and i'm
curious how the administration just um
you know squares us all together i mean
many voters do feel that inflation
incorrectly so predates the war and it
can't all be blamed on blindness
we've never we talked about inflation
long before there was an invasion but we
also know that factually if you look at
the data the average gas prices are up a
dollar 80 80 cents to a dollar it's
about a 25 we've seen increase in gas
prices since the start of this invasion
and we know energy prices is a big
driver of the inflation data so uh
that's if you look at the economic data
it doesn't mean i'm not suggesting every
person in this country looks at data and
assesses in that way they assess how
they feel and what the impacts are on
them we've long talked about since at
least i started this job since the
president came into office the impacts
of the pandemic on supply chains how
that's impacted a range of costs and
steps we're taking to address those
whether it's ensuring there's our goods
moving through ports
or other steps we can take to ensure
there are uh we fund chips manufacturing
because autos and the production of
autos maybe this was a case or an issue
when you were in michigan as def has
definitely been a driver over the case
of time so there's the course of time so
there's a lot of different issues but we
have there's no question that energy
prices continue to be month by month a
driver of inflationary data and we know
that since the start of this invasion
because of the reduction of oil and the
supply in the global oil market that
that uh from putin's invasion that that
is a big driver
go ahead
thanks so
much circling back to kelly's question
um about the new um atf uh nominee
can you describe any outreach that's
been done to the senate to ensure that
the um confirmation process goes more
smoothly than it did to the last
selection well because we're just
announcing him today i would expect it
would be from here forward right uh
obviously there are notifications that
happen in advance of any announcement
but um certainly we feel that um he is
somebody who has been supported from a
uh by been had bipartisan support in the
past is broadly supported by a number of
uh of um police groups um and that he's
an excellent candidate to lead uh to
lead um atf um but i wouldn't validate a
process going awry i think it's more
about uh whether or not uh republicans
in congress feel that there should be a
head of the atf and we believe there
should be and this is a person who is
eminently qualified to do that did that
notification process include senator
manchin's office i'm not going to get
into specifics of the notification
process but obviously since he's just
making this announcement today i would
expect that the outrage picks up from
here
the president was photographed over the
weekend in washington dc wearing a mask
um i just wanted to if you could go
through
when he masks and when he doesn't um
it would appear that he did not have a
close contact but correct me if that's
wrong he did not but we all make
decisions some people in here are
wearing masks to wear masks to make them
uh more comfortable or because they
chose to that day or maybe they're going
to be around family members or people
who may be immunocompromised or
vulnerable and president makes that
decision as as we all do as well
if can i just ask a kind of a broader
question related to the modi meeting
sure um
you've talked a lot about the
president's leadership in terms of
assembling a global
coalition against russia but that global
coalition isn't really global in the
sense that there are many countries out
there india is one of them that hasn't
really joined hasn't really taken side
they've sort of adopted a neutral stance
as caitlyn mentioned that the votes in
uh in the u.n including the the most
recent one on on taking rush out of the
u.n human rights council so is right i
mean do you do you all consider india
an example of a kind of failure to
to broaden the coalition to countries
like india beyond the sort of core
european countries um uh and if so what
you know was this call used or just does
the president see
pressure to use a call like this to
expand that global coalition even
further so that russia doesn't have the
kind of lifelines uh that it
that it needs to escape to escape the
sanctions
well i i would say building more than 50
percent far more than 50 percent of the
world's gdp into a global coalition is
hardly a failure i don't think anyone
would call that a failure um but what
india has done to date and our objective
and part of the objective of phone call
like this is to have a diplomatic
conversation to build on this right
recognizing that uh countries go at
different paces and uh taking steps to
uh support countries like ukraine what
what uh what india has done to date is
they have condemned the killings of
civilians in bucha
they have supported they've called
they've supported calls for an
independent investigation they've
provided over 90 tons of humanitarian
relief material to ukraine and its
neighbors to include medicine and other
essential relief earlier in the conflict
they also used its resources to evacuate
almost 150 foreign nationals for 18
different countries so part of our
objectives now is to build on that and
to encourage them to do more and that's
why it's important to have
leader-to-leader conversations
go ahead um the next mandate for public
transportation like trains plus yes and
airplanes um expires next week does the
white house or the administration have
any plans on extending that well it's a
decision made by the cdc so they will
make that uh decision and uh i'm not
aware of a decision being made at this
point but i would certainly point you to
them
go ahead
i'd like to switch gears here uh do you
have an update on brittany greiner um
russian state media reporting that her
detention has been extended at least
until may 19th
and also is it still a strategy not to
talk about her care or let me talk about
her case to keep from politicizing him
so the state department will have the
most up-to-date information i think it's
been out for some time the extension of
her detention there
we typically don't talk about cases in
advance of having a privacy act waiver
once we had a privacy act waiver we can
talk about it more but historically and
having formerly served at the state
department it is not typically
constructive to
uh talk a great deal about these cases
of individuals who are detained uh it
can historically impact our ability to
bring them home and that of course is
our objective but uh the state
department makes those determinations
they are in closest touch with efforts
to uh bring her home and that certainly
is our objective i have to ask trevor
reed or paul whelan
again you know these are of course
individuals and we want to do everything
we can and we are doing everything we
can to bring them home including raising
their cases at every opportunity
but typically it does not benefit the
cases to talk publicly about these cases
and i i would use evidence of some
individuals we've been able to bring
home from a variety of places in the
last several months where we didn't talk
a lot about them in advance our goal is
to bring them home go ahead thanks jen
uh on the president's conversation with
modi
wondering if the fact that mayor
garcetti doesn't have appear to have the
votes uh for confirmation right now
uh is there any concern around that
especially given how much the u.s wants
to press india not to cooperate with
russia was that you know the question of
his confirmation discussed and just i'm
not aware of it being a topic during the
call doesn't it still support his
nomination he does and then is there any
uh reaction on the french election and
the outcome with le pen and there's not
an outcome yet it goes to a runoff um so
obviously at this point we're not going
to speak to that
good thank you
bring the call from mr moody thank
president biden for organizing this call
can you give us a broader context into
it why this call was organized by
president by then and at this particular
time sure well i would say um we uh
india is an incredibly important partner
we consult very closely with india on a
range of issues um and this was an
opportunity to discuss uh work very
closely and discuss the consequences of
russia's unprovoked and unjustified war
against ukraine this builds on uh
discussions that have happened obviously
at a lower level than prime minister
modi and uh president uh biden but uh
certainly as a reflection of the value
the president sees in leader to leader
diplomacy and having conversations that
are candid that are direct but also
provide hopefully a pathway to
continuing to build on uh the steps
we've seen india take in recent weeks
given the situation that in pakistan
what is your assessment of the situation
there given that it's a nuclear powered
country situation's quite volatile in
terms of the new leadership or what
aspect security aspect of support
i don't have a new assessment from here
to offer i i would point you to the
defense department go ahead
several parkland parents including
manuel oliver who was taken into police
custody at the white house in february
while attempting to get the president's
attention will be attending today's rose
garden event does president fine and
have
any plans to meet with oliver or any of
the other parkland parents at the gun
violence prevention event i will check i
don't believe there are additional
meetings but obviously inviting uh these
incredibly courageous
parents who have um experienced the
worst thing that can happen to a parent
in their lives is a reflection of his
respect and all of our respect for the
work they've done their advocacy and
certainly an acknowledgement of that
yesterday on a separate topic yesterday
larry summers warned that a recession
could be on the way in the next two
years based on the inflation and
unemployment rates is the white house
also concerned that a recession could
hit in the next two years and what do
you make of his prescription of tariff
production strategic petroleum reserve
release adjusting immigration flows and
the federal government purchasing things
more inexpensively
well i would say a number of those
things we're already doing but i would
uh save to your earlier question
we of course continue to assess
are the state of our economy the health
of our economy
that's not a projection we have made
from here we believe that the economy is
strong we have created more jobs last
year than any year in american history
we saw the unemployment rate at 3.6
percent uh last month and we know that
as we're
continuing uh through an economic
recovery that there are areas that we
need to focus on including bringing down
costs for the american people but we are
continuing to assess we have not made
that projection from u.s government
economists that uh that larry summers
has made go ahead thanks jim uh on the
guns biden's approval rating uh on crime
is at 34 for some of the latest polling
that's at the same time as you know that
background checks have a lot of
approval from the american public as
well as their 63 that have supported the
ghost gun regulation that you guys are
finalizing today what's causing the
disconnect there is there any plan to
change the white house's messaging
moving forward from the events today
well i would first say that there's
nothing the president would love more
than signing background check
legislation into law that's something he
has been a leader a champion and
advocate for throughout his career and
also banning assault weapons he'd love
to be having an event in the rose garden
today signing legislation into law and
you're right it's hugely popular it
doesn't make a lot of sense except for
the hold the nra still seems to have
over components of government at this
point in time not our government but
people who are elected so i i wouldn't
say our messaging has changed i think
it's important uh and that's always been
the case but ghost guns we know are an
area where we can take steps to help
through executive authority and through
executive actions as the president is
doing today
to put in place background checks to put
in place a requirement of serial numbers
to bring them
more in line with with a range of other
guns but we'd love to get background
check broad background check legislation
do you have any response to the news
that jared kushner secured a two billion
dollar investment from a fund led by
saudi crown prince led by saudi arabia i
don't have any comment from here but
maybe they'll have a comment go ahead
thanks dan um going back to the
ukrainian the russian war austrian
chancellor carl niehauer is meeting with
putin in
moscow uh what does the administration
have to say about that what does he what
does the president think that will
achieve
well i think we've encouraged or
supported any efforts at diplomacy we've
though encouraged anyone who is speaking
with or meeting with however they're
engaging with president putin to also
engage with uh ukrainians they are the
country that is being invaded right now
and so if you're going to play a role in
diplomacy that is an especially
important component i would expect at
some point uh some will get a readout of
their conversation so i can't predict if
it's constructive or not follow-up on
pakistan if you will the new prime
minister i'm sheree
what arrangements does the
administration have to contact
him and uh what's moving forward on that
you mean whether there will be a call
from the president
i i don't have oh god citations are
there for his new administration too uh
i don't have a prediction of of a uh
call at this point in time i mean
obviously those are assessments made day
by day and especially after new leaders
are elected of course we have a long uh
uh strong and abiding relationship with
pakistan an important security
relationship and that will continue uh
under under new leaders go ahead thanks
you've said the two percent of the oil
coming from russia is imported into
india one to two one or two that's about
16 million barrels so far according to
contracts india has imported 13 million
barrels um since the war began or since
the invasion began of ukraine why not
just come out and ask them to help
isolate
the russian president i think the
president conveying our deputy national
security advisor conveying they should
take steps we encourage them to take
steps to diversify we're here to help
and assist in that and also conveying
it's not in their interest to increase
the import of russian oil
i think that speaks for itself but we
also know uh different countries are
going to make decisions based on what
their needs are
economically and what the needs are for
the people in their country we have of
course banned importing the import of
oil here
other countries have not done that so
it's not a violation of any sanctions or
any requirement or request from our end
on inflation um
you're saying that
because of the president's work then we
will see in the core inflation without
gas and food you'll see that core come
down and you see the results of this
work in that inflation i was making a
prediction not of that but of the fact
that you're going to see because of the
increase in the price of oil and you're
going to see an increase in the
overarching headline number
but the core inflation you're saying
that the president the core inflation as
as you know because you cover this very
closely does impact a range of factors
that uh we're still working to address
so but i was making a prediction about
the headline component okay thanks
everyone see you tomorrow
or only if you're going to iowa i guess
but
for those yes
wouldn't miss it
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
you